bienvenue en tout cas ici je suis ravi
d'être avec vous cet après midi et puis
avant de commencer à vous parler
d'économie en tout cas du nouveau monde
économique dans lequel nous sommes en
train de courir exactement je dois vous
faire un aveu pour être tout à fait
honnête c'est que lorsque j'ai été
contacté j'étais ravie de faire partie
de l'expérience tedx puisque je
l'utilisais moi même
par contre lorsqu'on m'a dit va falloir
trouver quelque chose où tu parle
d'humanité
j'ai dit ok mais moi je suis économies
je travaille sur la money money humanité
j'étais pas très inspiré pour être
honnête
et puis la chance a voulu que au moment
où j'ai reçu ce mail
j'étais dans le train et j'étais à
londres pour tout vous dire et puis je
me suis arrêté dans cette gare qui était
relativement glauque toute une série de
publicités étaient là et puis mon regard
s'est arrêté sur cette pub d'une grande
marque de carte bleue comme vous l'aurez
deviné qui nous disait que finalement le
fait d'utiliser de l'argent cash comme
disent les anglais des billets des
pièces c'est totalement out of date
vous faites partie de l'ancien
millénaire c'est ce que j'ai compris bon
pourquoi je me suis arrêté cette
publicité je sais pas vraiment en tout
cas elle était peut-être juste devant
moi et puis je repensais que cette
publicité
finalement elle avait quelque chose qui
était pas si nouveau que ça puisque
lorsque j'étais déjà étudiant à redon
lorsque j'étais déjà étudiant j'avais
déjà lu des types d'articles étaient
relativement proche de cela il y avait
une publicité en tout cas une affiche
qui m'avait marqué 7 et celle de vie
économistes ou qu'ils nous disaient que
déjà en 2007 on était on avait changé de
millénaire alors je suis désolé d'être
désobligeants envers vous n'a pas la
même différence d'âge mais il n'empêche
que on fait tous partie du paléolithique
puisque certainement vous utilisez
encore des billets des pièces et donc de
ce fait vous faites partie du
paléolithique de quelque chose qui
finalement aujourd'hui n'aurait plus
trop lieu d'être et donc la très très
vite je me suis vraiment rendu compte
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui était
assez commun et qui était même assez
souvent usitée ne serait ce que dans les
enseignements ou en tout cas de même
dans les théories philosophiques c'est
de faire le lien entre l'histoire de
l'humanité et l'histoire finalement
l'histoire monétaire et donc vous
connaissez tous un set cette fameuse ce
fameux dessin
sur l'histoire l'évolution de l'homme et
en général on associe avec l'évolution
de l'homme l'évolution des outils et la
monnaie fait partie de ceux là
donc une 2 2 questions sont posées à moi
c'est est ce que finalement on a
vraiment évolué c'est la réponse en tout
cas que j'essayerai veut de vous donner
est finalement est ce que est ce que les
évolutions de forme de monnaie elle dit
juste des choses sur l'évolution de
l'économie où elles disent davantage de
choses sur l'être humain et le terme d'
humanité pour cette conférence était
tout à fait tout à fait approprié alors
pourquoi on a tous cette idée que la
monnaie a disparu en tout cas pourquoi
même le génie du marketing et des
publicitaires fait qu on vous parle de
la fin de l'ère monétaire la réponse qui
est assez simple vous l'avez tous les
jours dans vos journaux c'est de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on brade la monnaie les
banques centrales vont mettre des taux
d'intérêt négatifs je me suis dit si je
vous parle de cela je vais perdre la
moitié de l'an fils qui à peu près le
cas de mon métier
donc j'ai dit non j'ai pas envie de
faire ça et en fait je vais essayer de
prendre un peu plus de recul et pourquoi
finalement la monnaie est en train de
changer ou pourquoi la monnaie a disparu
parce qu'on a une révolution que
beaucoup ont appelé la nouvelle
technologie de l'information et de la
communication mais l'ère du numérique
elle a changé non pas simplement notre
manière de consommer de produire mais
elle a surtout changé notre manière de
penser et la monnaie est évidemment a dû
suivre cette évolution donc la
révolution numérique elle a été vraiment
un point de basculement et au delà même
de notre quotidienneté la manière même
de de concevoir la monnaie il n'empêche
que j'avais ces deux références cette
publicité cet article je me suis dit est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très débattue cette idée de fin
d'une économie monétaire est est ce que
ça veut dire une économie sans monnaie
est ce que je vais arrêter de consommer
etc et je suis allé voir dans les
chiffres
et j'ai trouvé une étude anglaise qui
m'a fait particulièrement rire où on
essayait de poser la question aux
anglais ce que vous avez déjà fait un
chèque alors nous en france on est on
n'a pas fait d'études chez nous parce
qu'on est les champions des l'émission
de chèques on aimait nous mêmes plus de
chèque que l'ensemble de l'union
européenne - à poser cette question aux
anglais les anglais on leur a dit ban
est-ce que vous avez déjà mis émis au
moins un chèque dans votre vie ce que
vous avez déjà signé un chèque et si on
peut cette question chez les 18-35 ans
30% vous dise non moi je ne sais pas du
tout ce que c'est j'utilise ma carte
bleue
donc effectivement la preuve que je suis
quelqu'un du paléolithique
si on posait de questions chez les 18-25
ans évidemment le chiffre explose la
moitié de la population des moins de 25
ans n'a jamais même ne connaît pas
l'existence du chèque
ils ont peut-être vu leurs parents faire
ça ou leurs grands-parents pour les
étrennes mais finalement ils n'ont pas
l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
a encore fait partie de la réalité
alors si on va encore plus loin je veux
aller plus loin dans l'analyse et 100 %
des moins de 18 ans n'ont jamais émis un
chèque non pardon ça j'aurais pas dû
leur ajouté d'ailleurs bref tout ça pour
vous dire que cette question du chèque
c'est le paléolithique pour la plupart
des pour la plupart du commun des
mortels
et lorsqu'on regarde ceux qui sont le
plus en avance sur ces questions d'une
économie sans sans monnaie ce sont
évidemment les suédois qui ont toujours
une longueur d'avancé sur toute une
série de choses
et eux ils ont la particularité c'est
que simplement 2 % de l'argent qui
circule chez eux
c'est sous forme matérielle nous on est
à peu près à 10%
donc j'avais une certaine certitude
endéans ben c'est pas juste un cas isolé
il ya quelques pays qui font cela mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un monde sans
monnaie j'avais toujours pas plus
d'idées je me suis dit de quoi je vous
parlais finalement je vous donnais une
réalité mais qu'est ce que ça cache
derrière donc je suis allée comme tout
le monde tape et qu'ashley sur google et
voilà à peu près et voilà peu près
l'image qui est ressorti cette espèce de
nébuleuses vosges en espèces
d'aspirateurs géant qui aspireraient les
monnaies et si vous voyez bien derrière
vous avez toute une série de chiffres
qui sont des codes binaires et c est la
réalité qui est en train de s'offrir à
nous c'est une réalité d'une monnaie qui
n'existe plus au sens monnaie matériel
mais la monnaie va être sous forme de
code informatique ce qu'on appelle des
écriteaux monnaie ou des algorithmes et
donc la question qui se pose est celle
qui est ce qu'ils aimaient cette monnaie
qui est ce qui est à l'origine de cet
aspirateur et finalement qu'est-ce que
ça va signifier ou quelle va être notre
avenir de tout cela mais j'ai une
véritable certitude que on était
vraiment en train de changer demande
lorsque j'ai découvert grand drame de ma
vie que même les jeux de société se sont
mis à la cacher les économies puisque
regarder le nouveau monopoly donc là
aussi vous faites partie du
paléolithique si vous jouez encore avec
vos enfants et vos petits enfants avec
des monopoly des billets moi j'ai appris
à
comptez est certainement le fait que je
sois économiste n'est pas pour rien
grâce au monopoly
or aujourd'hui vos enfants vous allez
apprendre à compter avec à votre carte
et refuser votre carte est débitrice etc
la réalité c'est que même le monopoliser
a intégré le fait que la cache économie
c'est quelque chose qui n'existe plus on
va vivre dans un monde qui est qui est
sa monnaie donc la question c'est qui
est ce qui est mais cette monnaie en
fait qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'un
monde sans monnaie quelle réalité ça
peut avoir est là un nouveau monde s'est
ouvert à moi c'est ce que les
économistes appellent le gaf a le gaf à
vous le connaissez tous et vous
pratiquez tous gafas est l'acronyme pour
google apple facebook et amazon
quatre géants dans leur domaine ils sont
tellement géant et occupe votre
quotidien que une étude a été faite à
une étude marketing et regardez le
chiffre 55% vous tâchez jumez numérique
pardon ça soit de la navigation sur
internet des achats des playlists
musicales et toute une série d'autres
pratiques passe par l'une de ces quatre
entreprises ce qui veut dire que ces
quatre entreprises c'est finalement
celle qui gère nos vies notre accès en
tout cas notre manière de pouvoir
apprécier la vie j'ai ces quatre géants
qui sont certes des supers leaders qui
font des super profits mais la
particularité de ces quatre géants c'est
que ils ont aussi un autre pouvoir ils
ont créé en tout cas ils se sont
accaparés une nouvelle forme de monnaie
et leurs particularités c'est toutes ces
grandes entreprises
elle se caractérise par le fait qu'elles
font leur business dans une économie
évidemment qui est numérique c'est leur
business plan et surtout vous dans une
économie où la money cash n'est plus du
tout une réalité rien dire c'est pas les
premières compagnies qui acceptent la
carte bleue ou les cartes blanc ligne
mais elles elles sont allés encore plus
loin
elles ont créé leur propre système de
paiement vous avez évidemment amazon qui
avait déjà développé dès le début mais
vous avez aussi toute une série d'autres
marques allhiphop.com qui est le grand
amazon chinois et donc il ya des parts
de marché énorme google paye samsung
paypal etc
apple peut donc toutes ces grandes
entreprises elles ont compris que vous
vendre un produit c'est bien mais vous
permettre de payer ce produit et surtout
de le payer sans passer par le circuit
bancaire c'était certainement ça
l'avenir est donc ce qu'ont fait ces
entreprises
d'autres l'ont fait et donc on pourrait
augmenter le schéma quasiment deux fils
de façon infinie décimales
toute une série d'entreprises
aujourd'hui se font la guerre et la
vraie guerre c'est une guerre des
systèmes de paiement alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire finalement dans quel monde
on va être est le point commun de tout
cela c'est de se dire qu'on est rentré
dans une nouvelle ère et si on reprend
le premier dessin que je vous avais
passé ici valère l'air qui qui s'offre à
nous c'est finalement l'air de l'homo
numericus est en fait petit à petit on
va passer d'un mode de systèmes de
payement un autre mais particularité
c'est que ces modes de paiement il
laisse totalement de côté les banques et
c'est bien évidemment l'objectif de
toutes ces grandes entreprises et donc
vous avez l'ancien modèle les banques
qui vous vendent des terminaux de
paiement lorsque vous êtes commerçants
etc
et puis aujourd'hui grâce à l'ère du
numérique ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le business a simplement consister à
mettre en réseau en mettre en relation
des ordinateurs et en se disant un
payement ce n'est qu'un échange de
promesses de quelque chose ce que fait
le banquier moi je peux le faire car ça
ne veut pas dire que amazon a le droit
d'émettre sa propre monnaie ça serait
illégal évidemment je pourrais être
attaqué en justice en vous incitant de
faire de la fausse monnaie
ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas mon
propos mais par contre vous avez le
droit de démettre votre monnaie privée à
partir du moment où elle est échangeable
dans une autre monnaie est certainement
très vite compris et certainement vous
avez dû en entendre parler
il y à un japonais qui a émis ce qu'on
appelait la nouvelle monnaie ou la
monnaie du numérique et le fameux
bitcoin est donc ce bitcoin c'est l'idée
de dire je vais mettre une monnaie cette
monnaie peut être convertibles dans
n'importe quel autre monnaie et cette
monnaie leva pouvoir en fait faire la
même chose que ce que font toutes les
autres monnaies éteindre des dettes
la question c'est comment on fait pour
émettre de la monnaie lorsqu'on n'est
pas une banque ou comment fait pour
remettre de la monnaie légalement
lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on est une
entreprise privée
la technique de ce japonais là c'est
simple c'est de dire moi je vais créer
un programme
ce programme va vous ouvrir ce
portefeuille électronique et ce
portefeuille électronique vous avez vous
avez le droit d'envoyer comme pour des
sms des ordres d'achat et des ordres de
vente est en fait lorsque je fais cela
je fais la même chose que ce que fait
une banque
j'envoie des ordres de mon smartphone
évidemment je n'en vois un serveur qui
envoie un ordre un autre serveur qui va
vérifier la sécurité du créancier du
débiteur qui
ensuite passé l'ordre etc donc il
suffirait simplement d'avoir une très
bonne connexion en tout cas de créer un
réseau de réseaux comme on dit pour
finalement arriver à éteindre ce système
de paiement et l' avantage de cela c'est
que je passe sans mon banquier je n'ai
plus besoin de mon banquier pour pour
pouvoir faire ce type ce type de
transaction c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer ce qui va poser
quelques problèmes pour la suite de
l'histoire c'est que aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut indirectement et
mettre sa monnaie ce certaines règles à
partir du moment où il est capable de
sécuriser ses réseaux ses réseaux entre
entre les différents entre les
différents acteurs et donc ce que fait
bitcoin c'est tout simplement de créer
un code un cryptogramme vous allez payer
avec votre smartphone comme vous pouvez
le faire avec votre carte bleue et en
faisant cela vous permettez à deux
ordinateurs de se connecter il s'échange
des codes des algorithmes pour vous le
résultat c'est je suis payé dans une
certaines monnaies et cette monnaie elle
est convertible dans ma monnaie que je
connais le dollar l'euro le rouble tout
ce que vous voulez donc du coup
finalement il n'y a pas de tant de
problèmes que ça le problème qui va être
posée c'est que cette monnaie
elle va avoir un cours qui évidemment
évolué au cours du temps et c'est en ce
sens là où on revient quasiment au début
de l'histoire monétaire une monnaie
c'est évidemment le garantis de la
valeur lorsque je paye en euros je veux
être sûr qu'un euro sont toujours
acceptés comme un euro peu importe le
temps peu importe le lieu où je vais
payer si vous payez avec des bitcoins
entre le moment où vous allez mettre la
charrue moment où vous allez être débité
cette valeur peut peut évidemment
changer à la hausse ou à la baisse
particularité de cette monnaie c'est que
comme tout se passe par des réseaux
d'interconnexion
il ya une sécurité certes qui est jugé
comme plus efficace qu'une carte bleue
aucune banque par contre il ya une un
anonymat qui est garanti et ce qui n'est
pas sans poser problème pour à des
opérations qui serait moins - légal et
donc la question que je me suis posée
c'est est ce que finalement je dois vous
parler de ce petit koné est ce que c'est
l'avenir est ce que cette mort cette
monnaie qui semble être une nouvelle
monnaie mais en même temps qui semble
être risqué puisque je suis jamais sur
sa valeur je peux gagner comme je peux
perdre
est-ce que c'est finalement l'avenir je
me suis référé à mes histoires en tout
cas mes cours d'histoire économique et
je me rappelle toujours de cette phrase
on a toujours des phrases mythiques qui
restent ne sais pas pourquoi et je me
rappelais de cette phrase d'un
économiste qui disait la mauvaise
monnaie chasse la bonne au moment où on
avait à la fois des pièces d'or et des
pièces d'argent tout le monde conserver
les pièces d'or parce qu'elle était
jugée comme de meilleures valeurs et
donc du coup tout le monde paye en
argent l'argent qui avait une valeur
plus faible résultat alors est sorti de
circulation et je me suis dit ce que
sait pas ce qui va se passer avec le
bitcoin le bitcoin est très dangereux ça
peut être une monnaie spéculative mais
en même temps si on va conserver des
monnaies qui sont jugés comme plus sûr
est ce qu'il va pas se produire s'être
même chose et c'est certainement là
dessus que nos ministres ont en tout cas
nos grandes institutions sont en train
de réfléchir puisque cette monnaie va
poser problème pour prélever l'impôt
pour prélever la tva ou en tout cas pour
assurer la sécurité de ceux qui les
mettent donc est ce que cette monnaie va
chasser ou cette mauvaise monnaie va
chasser une bonne monnaie là question
évidemment va rester posés mais je peux
pas faire de prospective économique je
vous laisserai libre d'en juger par
contre pour terminer cette conférence je
me suis dit est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
retient de tout ça est ce que finalement
on a évolué j'ai commencé ce switch en
vous montrant une photo du paléolithique
ou en tout cas de quelques dinosaures
l'homme fabrique ces outils l'homme a
fabriqué sa monnaie fabriquer ces pièces
et puis aujourd'hui où est-on arrivé on
arrivait bas tout simplement à toute une
série format titien on pourra appeler
des geeks parfois sous des termes un peu
comique et qui vont simplement mettre en
réseau des ordinateurs est ce que ça
veut dire qu'on a évolué si on reprend
notre premier schéma entre l'homme qui
marcher à quatre pattes et puis celui
qui se dresse voir celui qui va être
courbé
est ce que c'est ça vraiment l'évolution
monétaire en tout cas c'est l'histoire
qui nous le dira je vous remercie